like if we're born gay then why are all
the gay people going up like why are
there so many more and I was thinking
about this I'm like hey women are just
we believe anything like once you start
to think of women of just these like
malleable and I know it's it's like
Pearl you're a woman I mean I was
obsessed with Japan like 15 years ago
you know what I mean it's in all of us
so it's like when you think of us as
these malleable creatures and you
realize that all the changes in society
are just them putting random in our
phone so now they're like everyone's gay
and all the women are like I'm gay and
they're like everyone's trans and women
are like I'm trans or the men that have
a woman's spirit in them do the same
thing so they're like put in the birth
control in the water so the men become
women so they can just like manipulate
everyone